so right now I live in Boston um they're
on the East Coast many of my friends
there who has been there for a while
they have a story they all I remember
the day that this happened on August
14th 2003 several states in the American
Northeast and Midwest part of Canada
experienced what was then the second
biggest blackout of all time in the
world 55 million people lost power some
of them lost power for up to a week and
what could cause so much chaos given
that no foreign power has ever taken
down America's electric grid especially
on this scale who was this master
criminal who excessively launched an
attack on our own infrastructure the
culprit was a tree it was a nice summer
day
so people turn on their air conditioning
which heated up the wires and because
metal expands when it's heated that
caused the wires to sag and it's sagged
enough that a tree in Ohio could reach
to that wire and set it on fire which is
okay this is actually normal this
happens all the time and this was
usually only resulted in one station one
power station being knocked out but due
to a software bug they couldn't send an
automated alerts to its neighboring
power stations so it took its a electric
load and it passed it off to its
neighboring power stations which caused
them to overload so to cast their load
on to their neighbors which caused them
to overload which created a vicious
cycle and spread throughout an entire
causing a blackout this isn't the only
example of something bad cascading
throughout an entire network for example
the 2008 financial crisis a handful of
banks in the US made some bad bets and
in Greece burns that's because we're
living in such a connected economy for
better and for worse or think about
epidemics one patient zero a little bit
while later millions die best because
were already connected again for better
or for worse and underlying all these
systems is something called attractors
they called attractors because they
attract the system towards different
things in this case they all attract the
system towards failure so imagine you
have a ball on a naughty shaped Hill and
let's say that the left right position
represents you know how good or bad
something is so if the ball is way on
the left okay that's good that means
none of the power stations have failed
and all the banks are still alive
but the ball was all the way to the
right that means power stations have all
failed the banks are all bankrupt I also
want to clarify that the up/down axis is
not good or bad it's stable or unstable
so if something's really if the ball is
really high up in the air it's pretty
unstable but it's down grounded close to
the earth it's pretty stable and now
stable and unstable again words are
terrible they have positive and negative
connotations but here's the thing here
we have a good but unstable situation
and also a bad but very stable situation
and these mountains are what we saw
earlier reinforcing loops a ball on a
hill AB one reinforcing loop in the
power station example is power station
fails and cascades onto the next ones or
a bank fails in that cascade on to the
next banks it keeps the ball rolling
in the valleys those correspond to
balancing loops Valley for example for
the power station example you know
eventually around our power stations to
make fail and for banks eventually you
run out of banks to make bankrupt so the
ball stops at the bottom of that Valley
and these valleys are the attractors
because they attract the ball to a
certain point in this case failure so
now you imagine you are standing next to
this ball and you're a complete jerk so
you push it a little bit with a little
small nudge it gets past a tipping point
and then gravity takes over the ball
will quickly roll down the reinforcing
loop of the mountain and into the
balancing loop the valley the attractor
the valley of death and furthermore you
can see that if you were to go down and
actually be nice for once and try to
undo all your damage it would take you a
lot more effort then what it took you to
push the ball in the first place all the
way down that's why a blackout can't
cascade in a few hours but fixing it
took four weeks or why the recession can
spread around a globe in a few months
but fixing it took
we're still living through the
consequences
you